說實在的我們一直覺得NVIDIA的對手只有一個就是Google
那它只有一個對手一個Google的原因是因為Google它做它的TPU還有它的架構
它做了十年以上
它不是一朝一夕這個市場紅了忽然跳進來說我要做的
AI時代來臨 投資也能充滿智慧
富邦AI Pro專業分析資料 透視趨勢
輕鬆一點掌握全球市場脈動
有AI 投資更Pro
現在就點擊知識欄 趕快去下載
歡迎收看富邦政策YouTube頻道 我是Sabrina
上一集我們談到AI商業化和推理需求崛起帶來的產業變化
不過近期市場也開始出現了不同聲音
甚至開始檢討AI投資效益
今天我們就從需求面來出發
來看看AI長線成長動能在哪裡
一樣邀請到騰訊投資的投資長陳振華
也是大家熟悉的建掌來和我們聊聊
建掌好
哈嘍 各位觀眾朋友大家好
近期美國已經有企業開始降低AI工具的使用率
甚至暫停部分的AI專案
想請教建長
您怎麼看這個現象
有哪些的產業對AI的需求
可能是比較具有持續性的呢
針對這個問題我們覺得
其實是因為之前用太多了
倒不是說忽然AI需求不見
用太多的原因其實是
之前就是矽谷他們對人力的評價
評估它的KPI的一個方式
他們那時候叫做Token Maxing
Token Maxing就是你用了越多Token
你的績效就越好
那當然你如果都沒有用Token
也就是你都沒有在使用
AI這些工具的話
那你就會被Fire掉
就是沒有工作
所以每個人就是不管我會不會用
我都要毛起來用
就是為用而用
對 我能用多少就用多少
因為用越多績效越好
反正是公司出錢嘛
所以就能用多少就用多少
所以這個東西就導致很多
無謂的浪費
所以才會說很多企業忽然發現
他們打算今年用在AI的
這個Budget預算
怎麼一下就用完了
像Uber 微軟 Facebook
Facebook都有類似的一些comment
就是忽然發現在這個AI的使用上的
這個budget使用的太多
所以他們現在就要來重新評估
這個方式
就說特別是現在AI在不同的應用上
它不同的模型價差其實非常大
我們知道其實很多東西你
特別我們剛剛有提到開源模型
開源模型你的定價就比較便宜
簡單所謂便宜就是我
一個100萬個token
它處理大概要多少錢
所以變成說企業會開始做區分
就是便宜的你們儘量用
無所謂還是隨便鼓勵你們用
但是貴的可能只有幾個老闆
或者幾個長官
或者叫特別approved
你才可以去用到這些
比較貴的這些模型
然後去跑你那些相關應用
所以我覺得其實是
之前有一度過度浪費的一個現象
那現在開始比較開源節流
就開始注意我們的
這個花費上要有效率
那當然以時空背景來講
今年上半年做這樣的一個
績效評估可能有它的必要
那理由是它強迫每個人去選擇
怎麼用AI
你不會用就被fire掉嘛
所以強迫每個人都要用
那每個人都學了之後
當然現在就告訴你說
這個工具大家都會了
那就開始如何更有效的利用它
然後不要浪費
大概是這樣的一些狀況
所以目前我們來看
它倒是一個促進了
大家使用AI變得更普及的
一個政策
那現在政策效果也達到了
那當然就開始要做一些
省成本的一個動作
所以如果長線需求是存在的
那接下來就是要看
這些需求到底是真需求
還是市場提前反映
那四大CSP巨頭
他持續的增加AI資本支出
市場也擔心是不是有提前備貨
或是重複薩丹的情況
那目前AI產業是真需求帶動
還是說包含了部分預期性的需求
應該說現在一定有一些
Double Booking的現象
這個在市場上是共識
那所以其實第一個就幾個角度來看
我們如果看整個供應鏈的庫存
那包括你看下游的這個
比如說HPDALE這些品牌上
或是像ODM比如說鴻海廣達
那偉創這些公司
或者是你在看一些網通
什麼Cisco Arista
其實發現每家公司的庫存都上來了
所以其實今年大家有沒有在提前準備
然後有一些超額下單的現象
因為大家也都擔心
比如最明顯的擔心記憶體缺貨
然後擔心各個那些什麼NLCC缺貨
各種各樣的東西
都有可能有缺貨的狀況
所以為了即將來臨的
這個CSP的這個資本支出
所以大家都有這樣的一個
超額下單的狀況
那在CSP本身也有類似的狀況
就是說現在一個大家常常在觀察是
他們在美國蓋Data Center
蓋得並不是很順利
因為缺電
然後又有居民抗爭
那所以你做這些基礎建設
其實是需要時間
而且需要特別是環評等等
各方面的這些事情
那這兩年因為你蓋了一堆資料中心
導致電費大漲
那所以居民的反彈其實非常多
有一些州就開始宣佈說
我可能讓你資料中心要比較晚開始建
或是評估時間要久一點
那這個反應在資料中心上面
就是他們自己手上的庫存其實也在增加
那目前幾大CSP有公佈這個數字是
像Google 然後像Meta
他們其實有公佈就是類似我買的這些東西
但是還沒有拿來用的
那他就直接放在類似庫存的這個項目裡面
那這個數字其實在過去幾季是持續增加
所以等於是說他們也備了一些的
比如說買了一個NVIDIA GPU放在那邊不動
那等著資料中心蓋好才能把它放進去
所以就放在這個地方
那它的供應商其實也背了一堆庫存
所以整個供應鏈現在有沒有超額庫存的現象
那其實是有的
那只是剛剛講的
因為目前需求成長太快
所以導致大家現在還不太擔心
因為大家現在發現就是
需求是增加非常快嘛
所以剛剛講的Google、Meta
他們暫時可能還不擔心我手上有這堆庫存
因為他們覺得只要我這條中心蓋好
我立刻把它丟進去
我馬上就可以使用到
我還要再訂下一批
所以他們目前在供應鏈上也沒有收手
他們還是買得很積極
但市場有沒有Double Booking
的確有
所以當然回過頭來我們還是要觀察
最終的這個消費者對AI的需求
這算力需求是不是一直快速的增長
那如果有slow down的現象的時候
可能就要小心這個double booking的現象
那談到AI長期需求晶片
它還是最關鍵的基礎設施
目前市場除了NVIDIA的GPU之外
各大科技廠也積極的佈局ASIC
希望透過客製化的晶片來提升騷能並降低成本
那您認為ASIC有機會挑戰GPU的主導地位嗎
說實在的我們一直覺得NVIDIA的對手只有一個就是Google
那它只有對手一個Google的原因是因為Google
它做它的TPU還有它的架構
它做了十年以上
它不是一朝一夕這個市場紅了
忽然跳進來說我要做的
忽然紅了跳進來要做的是Google以外的其他人
包括Amazon其實稍微沒有那麼近跳進來
但是也是大概這三四年才跳進來做的
那然後Microsoft的Meta其實都更近
就是最近才幾年才忽然跳進來要做
那其實做GPU或是做這個AI加速器
它並沒有想象中那麼簡單
那一般來講我們覺得這個市場
你至少要有三個相關的主要的技術
一個當然是GPU本身嘛
加速器本身的這個技術
另外一方面你要有高速的網路傳輸的
這個相關的一些IP
那還有就是你在做整個Networking的
這個Topology的一個網路架構的一個設計
那這三個都Ready的
目前大概就只有剛剛講的NVIDIA跟Google
這兩家公司
其他人其實都沒有
所以目前我們常常看到
很多家公司三天兩頭都宣佈說
我要來做這個產品
但最後他們其實都會卡在
他們缺東缺西
然後做不起來
那我還有一點可以補充一下
就是說其實我們剛提到的這個
現在輝達或Google
他們來做這個AI伺服器
或整個這個AI的晶片
他們的架構
基本上是一整個系統在做設計
所以設計整個系統的意思
它不是單單賣晶片
我們剛講除了這幾個
跟晶片相關的之外
他裡面各種各樣的零組件
他都要參與設計
然後參與主導
然後跟上下游去提前布可產能
說你要為我東西
然後準備多少產能
然後開始跟我做相關的一些合作
那甚至他要出錢
所以比如最明顯的
我們說光通訊來講
大家都知道未來幾年
CPU起來之後
最缺的 成長最快的就是光
特別是雷射
那所以怎麼辦呢
兩大雷射廠
Coherent Lument
輝達就直接投資
然後康寧Vita就直接投資
所以未來這些人擴的產能
基本上大部分就被NVIDIA給掌控了
那其他的人要跳進來的時候
我就算這邊剛剛講的幾個架構的東西都有了
我到來找別的component的時候
哇 我去哪裡找
這又會是另外一個問題
他可能只能找二線廠
或是別人外溢出來的一些東西
所以整個供應鏈的掌握
其實輝達跟Google
他們其實這方面做了很多投資
然後相關的佈局都已經做得很完整了
要跟他們競爭其實沒有這麼容易
聽起來不論是GPU或者是ASIC的發展
其實都會帶動先進製程和先進封裝的需求
AI也正在改變整個半導體產業的資本配置
那您認為未來半導體供應鏈的競爭重心
還會有哪些新的變化呢
其實目前來看其實都要再看新的技術
那比如說像一般我們原本早期看半導體技術
就看臺積電的先進製程
那當然這幾年開始看先進封裝
就是CoreOS SOIC等等的東西
那下一步的話當然就是Koos發展到一個瓶頸
那可能接下來最近在討論比較多一個是Kopos
就是變成面板機的封裝嘛
那面板機封裝但它還是有一些問題
就是它Koos其實差不多的類似的製程
只是從圓的變方的嘛
所以原本有的挖比舉的問題還是會有
所以大家在考慮下一代比如說做玻璃基板
那就是底下的基板變成有那個glass core
用玻璃做核心
然後你要做TGV挖孔
那然後去做這個玻璃基板
那有一些相關的玻璃基板的機會
那或者是像另外一個
比如最近大家開始討論Intel的ENIB
就EMIB
那EMIB這個技術
現在看起來在做到更大尺寸的面板
這個晶片的時候
可能也是一個可以考慮的方向
所以最近報紙也開始寫了
就EMIB臺積電也開始考慮
做一些EMIB-like的一個製程
那當然還有像NVIDIA自己
之前跳出來一個技術叫COOP
就是說我是從
現在COOP是on Subtrait
那它可能直接把Subtrait去掉
變成一個PCB
做一個更大的一個
就是剛講他已經不是賣單一個晶片了
我直接是賣一個主機板的
這種感覺給你
就一整個架構都幫你做好了
那當然這裡面的技術都有很多要挑戰
要發展的一些地方
所以每一個技術如果有一些突破的話
當然都可能對供需造成一些變化了
那比如說剛剛講的
如果說Co-op成功了
你可能基板這一塊的需求忽然就沒有
大家都會覺得基板好像很緊張
那當然最近看起來這個PCB本身有點難做
所以他可能又用類似載板的技術回來做
所以又不一定是換掉這個載板
那另外比如說像
如果你是用類似Intel EMIB的這種技術
你做完的話你就不需要臺積電的CLW
你就可以跳脫臺積電的掌控
那當然如果是臺積電的角度
他就再去做別的一些技術
比如說SOIC你要做3D堆疊
你別的地方跑掉這邊還是掌握在我這邊
所以還滿有趣的就是
隨著你這封裝技術的變化
那每家各自有各自的佈局
那未來的供應鏈
可能就會有些競合關係的一些
更多的一些故事可以去看
大概是這樣子
非常感謝建掌精彩的分享
也讓我們對AI長線需求
半導體產業發展
有了更深入的瞭解
如果喜歡這集內容
歡迎按贊訂閱
並開啟手鈴鐺
下一集我們要進一步來探討
AI高檔震盪下的投資佈局
我們下期見
拜拜